this video was so hard to put together  basically I was supposed to go to Dubai  and film it in Dubai and this actually  Brittany Renner did not want to go to  Dubai so it's a good thing that we  actually ended up doing in London in  London because she wouldn't have ended  up being able to go  um so we're gonna go to Dubai and do a  panel there and I bought tickets I  bought hotels but I can't  I can't even pay back which so I spent a  lot of money basically I found out last  minute like a day or two out before I  was supposed to fly my manager went to  Dubai and he had an emergency passport  they don't accept those there I couldn't  get into Dubai either because my  passport expires within six months so  I'm like last minute trying to get a  passport I go to the Embassy can't go I  have to cancel all the flights tell  everyone not to come blah blah blah so  then  um Tate agrees to come to us